I am you you are me together we make a
perfect jolly I went on down we know
that always be around two three
our relationship is complicated
sometimes it's not to remember
that you're even feeling lonely and
Semba facing hardships that we come back
you'll help me come through the other
side you build up my confidence and
raise my time together there's nothing
that we can't face just as long as we
play some sound it's just a shame that I
hate
you're insufferable you're acnes
terrible exciting disposition is
completely unbearable and worst of all
you've got no friends they're just on
the Internet you're a waste of space
you've got no lifeguard of all from your
face you should take a knife to your
head and do it before I do it instead
you got that perfect Eva mate in fact
you're way too easy to hate what
nineteen-year-old can't get a date I
guess it's late now you'll never find a
soul mate you're going to die alone on
your own making crappy YouTube video I
am you together we make a salty unfit
you're artsy and funny forget we teach
Arling down we know that
you only ever have each other around
our relationship is company sometimes
it's hard to remember that you're even
bamba' facing on ships that we combat
the signs you build up my confidence and
raise my prize together there's nothing
we come things just as long as we
embrace a cell you know that I really
really really love you
yeah even though it's made in the same
you need to be able to love yourself but
not in that way what way yeah
you've just had the almost imponderable
joy of watching Charlie is so cool like
which makes you like cool that'll do
lad that'll do look there's nobody there
magic magic of video